opération séduction à la maison du
charolais accompagné de la secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes amélie
de montchalin j'irai me decerle
l'agriculteur et député européen invite
ses collègues du parlement à découvrir
les richesses de son terroir
nous allons bientôt prendre des
décisions importantes dans la politique
agricole commune
c'est plutôt bien de savoir ce qu'il se
passe sur le terrain de voir ce dont les
gens ont vraiment besoin
au menu la filière bovine mais aussi les
nombreuses interrogations sur l'avenir
de la profession
très honnêtement on va y aller franco de
la paix ou la fraude aux anglais c'est
très important qu'on puisse bien montrer
au niveau européen que la france a des
particularités il ya des spécificités
qu'il ya des labels qu'elle a aussi des
défis et qu'il faut qu'on s'organise
croire le monde dans nos filières
pendant les meilleurs prix mais
effectivement face à la concurrence
mondiale
ces clés d'avoir non seulement une
stratégie française cohérence avec les
outils européens donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est là aujourd'hui
l'europe doit apporter une réponse à la
situation catastrophique je pense que
traverse le monde agricole les
agriculteurs européens ont besoin d'une
direction d'un cap est derrière tout ça
il leur faudra bien sûr du revenu et
peut-être plus particulièrement en
france un peu plus de considération
après cette première journée de débats
aux côtés des éleveurs de bovins et de
caprins le groupe parlementaire se
rendra demain en franche comté
il rencontrera des producteurs de
compter et de porc il s'intéressera
aussi à la transmission à l'installation
un dossier urgent la profession
d'agriculteur peine à séduire les jeunes
générations